vamos a hablar desde mi experiencia como
profesor universitario
de la presencia y la ausencia de las
personas con discapacidad en la
inclusión educativa
y eso es malo como los pretextos para
conversar esta tarde
como profesor universitario y los invito
a una primera lectura
a propósito de esta expresión presencia
y ausencia propongo que se lea desde de
herida
y que no se entienda como antónimos como
la lógica binaria
de los contrarios aquí presencia y
ausencia son una unidad
porque las personas con discapacidad
estamos presentes en la educación a
través de los siglos y ausencia aquí
invito a que se lea como esos momentos
donde la persona ha sido invisibilizada
pero a pesar de esa ausencia hay una
huella
bueno vamos a intentar rastrear esa o
ella
en la información tuve que leer
a pie y amigos
y los leí a ambos
no los resúmenes
no tú lees esto yo leo esto y hacemos
una exposición no la lógica nuestra
nueva es
tampoco la del scop y page
y en vigotsky encuentro las primeras
huellas y voy a citar al líder man con
el escritor norteamericano que tiene el
hermoso texto que se llama aprender a
pensar conmigo
natacha vigotsky en la escuela
norteamericana es una cosa que es de
verdad un hallazgo sorprendente
vigotsky durante muchos años en
occidente no se leyó en ese texto y voy
a recuperar un diálogo entre una niña
una nena y un niño ayala voy a llamar
carolina por la sonoridad y la belleza
del nombre carolina a él juanito para
reivindicar reivindicar ese niño
indisciplinado que tenemos entonces
juanito llegada de visita donde carolina
y carolina le dice mira mis padres me
trajeron arcilla de regalo
e invita a juanito a que haga algo él
toma la arcilla rápidamente hace una
bola y le dice hecho un durazno se lo
entrega en la mano ella lo toca y le
dice mira qué tontería juanito esto no
es un durazno yo te voy a enseñar a
hacer honduras
ella toma un poquitico de arcilla hace
una bolita y dice mira está la semilla
coge más arcilla y comienza a envolverla
y esta es la carne que te comes que te
gusta después coge otro poquito y lo
envolví les está en la piel
juanito se resiste y dice yo los veo
igual
y ella le dice no no no mira qué pena no
son iguales
se resiste y le dice mira sabes que
carolina hace una cabeza es así claro
mira yo te enseño cómo es una cabeza
empiezo por la garganta desde adentro
hago la boca los dientes los labios
empujó hacia afuera hago la caja
craneana en pulso por acá formó la nariz
y carolina le dice mira a juanito así se
hace una cabeza
él vuelve a dar la pelea
y le dice pero
yo lo hago de afuera hacia adentro ya lo
dicen tú siempre te quedas afuera
yo lo hago de adentro hacia afuera
afirma ella y él definitivamente se
rinde y le dicen la mira sabes que
carolina yo sólo sé una forma de hacer
las cosas
ella vencedora le dice no
antes sabías una manera
ahora sabes dos maneras
esas herramientas las tenemos los
profesores
sabemos que hay más de un método
sabemos que hay más de una escuela de
pensamiento sabemos que hay más de una
teoría del conocimiento y sigo buscando
huellas
y voy a hablar porque yo no soy el único
profesor ciego y espero no ser el último
hay profesores ciegos
como el doctor
rafael campo sociólogo de la universidad
javeriana maestro durante muchos años
un gran amigo mío henri economista
doctor en economía de la universidad del
valle también profesor
doctor gallego profesor de doctorado en
los análisis pero el más célebre de los
maestros ciegos es nicolás sounders fund
es un inglés del siglo 18 maestro de
matemática y física
ciego y enseñaba óptica
y esas son las huellas de los ciervos
como maestros y como estudiantes
y en la filosofía hay tres momentos
1 la carta de los ciegos
que se te dé dinero también siglo 18
donde él inclusive plantea un debate muy
interesante a propósito de la ceguera
porque él no pregunta si los ciegos
conocen
si es posible que conozcan o no el no
pregunta es
y él pregunta es como conoce
como conoce
porque sabe que hay un largo debate en
la filosofía a propósito del
conocimiento tú tienes el mundo ideal de
platón de espalda a la realidad
y tienes del otro lado el mundo
perceptual de aristóteles
ahí tienes las dos líneas
y también tienes
esos filósofos
que voluntariamente
se quedan ciegos
renuncian a la visión para poder conocer
el mundo
todas esas huellas están ahí en la
pedagogía
y los maestros deberíamos saberlas y
conocerlas
porque aquí es donde yo marco distancia
cuando comenzamos a hablar de inclusión
y para hablar de inclusión tenemos que
hablar de participación que son los
procesos del siglo 21 por eso la
definición de discapacidad se da en el
siglo 21
discapacidad es la resultante de un
interactuar de un interactuar
de una persona con deficiencia
entiéndase persona ciega o personas
sordas
con las barreras del entorno que le
impiden su participación
estamos en una sociedad para participar
eso es inclusión
participar
las barreras las barreras las deberíamos
mitigar desestructurar eliminar acabar
la palabra que más les guste
y hay varios elementos para eliminar
esas barreras y no es un único elemento
son múltiples los ajustes razonables el
diseño universal
y las barreras pueden ser de acceso al
entorno físico o virtual
barreras actitudinales o culturales
y nosotros hemos asumido que en la
educación la gran barrera es el maestro
y que el maestro requiere de formación
capacitación y preparación
y ahí es donde yo tomo distancia porque
la educación tiene un entorno físico o
virtual
tiene unos saberes tiene un conocimiento
ahora lo que necesitamos para el siglo
21 es el maestro del siglo xxi
porque si es ese maestro
si estamos en problemas
pero hemos invertido millones de dólares
en formar preparar y capacitar maestros
y la inclusión todavía tiene grandes
debates por dar
pero es que también está el texto
pero el texto también se diluye en el
siglo 21 y aparece el hipertexto
el texto y el hipertexto también tienen
que ser accesibles
este es otro ajuste razonable y que está
en función de la inclusión
a veces es más fácil decir que no son
las cosas o como no son las cosas
inclusión no es el paraíso terrenal
hecho a imagen y semejanza del educador
espacial especial ni del terapeuta ni
del maestro
eso no es inclusión
inclusión no es preparar el infierno
para darle la bienvenida a los monstruos
a los anormales y a los subnormales
bueno al superdotado tampoco
la base no es inclusión inclusión no es
el paraíso
inclusión es un proceso que en términos
de borges es como la lluvia o yo les
diría que es como el amar sólo es
posible en el presente ahora
o como decía yupanqui en esta comunión
de soledades
donde nos encontramos
donde recuperamos la diferencia para
dialogar para conversar
porque el estudiante debe ser bienvenido
y la escuela tiene que ser pensada desde
la hospitalidad y el maestro antes de
prepararse tiene que ser disponible
estar dispuesto a
y hay una relación ética
porque la inclusión es para
hacer un mundo mejor
para todos para hacer un mundo justo
bueno ustedes dirán carreta teoría
amigos de vida
nada yo soy maestro
y trabajo en la universidades
y me encuentro con la diferencia y con
la diversidad
mire que hay la lógica no es el
estudiante
no es ese otro relato que nos andan
vendiendo por ahí que es que los niños
con discapacidad les hacen bullying en
el colegio
eso es parcialmente verdad pero también
hice bullying en el colegio yo
y eso que ahora llaman bullying bueno
listo en mi nombre es yang lerman
para cualquier mensaje que me manden a
partir del comentario que siguen o por
qué
yo le hice bullying a mis compañeras
niñas de colegio
y yo era estudiante cierto
bueno ahora como profesora universitario
muchas veces llego al salón de clase
llegó primero que mis estudiantes a las
casas
me siento tengo un gesto
también me seduce en estas pantallas
sí creo que comparte esa tarea con
muchos de mis congéneres
pues tengo este gesto en clase de
sentarme aquí a chequear la pantalla a
mirar qué está pasando
pues mis estudiantes como todos los
estudiantes entran despistados se van
sentando y algunos han huido en la
universidad que por ahí hay un profesor
ciego es como que cuchichean como que
miran al tipo pero el tipo no los mira
el tipo de pronto se da media vuelta se
para y comienza a hablar
igual otros se pierden en su pantalla de
celular
otros a comer otros a mirarse otros a
enamorarse y unos que otros estudiantes
comienzan a poner cuidado crash
lo primero que le llama la atención a
mis estudiantes es que les preguntó su
nombre y siempre los llamó por su nombre
yo puedo hablar como se han dado cuenta
tres horas seguidas
ah
pero la idea no es admitir que el
estudiante entre se me pierda y no
existe el diálogo entonces lo invitó a
conversar y lo llamó por su nombre eso
es lo primero que le llama la atención a
ellos
y comienzan a aparecer tímidamente las
preguntas y les digo mire en mi clase
siempre va a haber un espacio para
hablar
les digo dedicamos una sesión de clase
pero eso sí es como la lucha libre
todo vale
yo no pongo restricciones ustedes
preguntan lo que quieren preguntar y por
supuesto que me preguntan de todo y yo
contesto de todo
es más he tenido cursos
donde para mi clase para el ejercicio de
mi clase
pongo películas
y esa parte es fascinante porque
entonces ellos ven las películas en
carreta y claro cada uno de ellos tiene
su lectura a propósito de la película
aquí un comentario a propósito de cine
para todos cine para todos es un
proyecto de inclusión no sólo por el
ejercicio del desarrollo y el desafío
tecnológico no sólo por la
audiodescripción sino porque potencia un
diálogo entre la persona con
discapacidad y sus pares en torno a una
historia a una película
esto yo me siento con mis estudiantes
hablar de esa película
entonces ahí lo sacó de su centro
ay se desplazan porque yo tengo una
lectura de la imagen y de la historia
y ahí sí que la cosa se pone más
interesante porque entonces muchas veces
la pregunta es cómo no es como lo hace
sino nada nada nada ese mambo
y entonces viene la pregunta del millón
venga profe usted el cielo o si ve
y les digo mire esa pregunta es la única
pregunta que yo no contesto nunca nunca
por dos razones
porque si un día
me da por echar un piropo y decirle
alguna niña
es muy poco azul para tanto cielo
piropo de carlos puebla parece bellísimo
y resulta que si yo he hecho el piropo
de carlos puebla y preciso la niña está
vestida de azul
pues cuál es la respuesta ese man ve
pero de lo contrario
la hacia dora se equivoca me deja
atravesada la silla la papelera voy
caminando me tropiezo a ese amanecido
entonces eterna duda
eterna
mire
el desafío de la inclusión es ese
diálogo con el otro es ese encuentro con
el otro cuando un niño sordo
llega el salón de clase
nos trae la experiencia humana más
hermosa
la lengua de señas
porque es la combinación perfecta de la
inteligencia y la belleza
la lengua de señas
despierta en todos los niños y en todas
las niñas
potenciales increíbles esto no es
metáfora
y es verdad
es una lengua que te habla
desde el silencio desde el movimiento
desde el gesto desde la mirada
es un discurso inteligente coherente con
estructura y gramática
despierta la inteligencia la curiosidad
el niño sordo no viene a ser incluido
viene a proponerte un diálogo una
conversación un desafío
no al fonoaudiólogo no no ya está hecho
la
a su par a los niños ya las niñas a eso
viene al salón de clase
soy dial hermen y les voy a dar las
gracias por su tiempo y su paciencia
[Aplausos]